hey y'all and welcome to the seventh
Enterprise Community Meetup where we
talk about endtoend data science
workflows with posit team my name is
Simon couch and I work on free and open
source packages for machine learning and
R at
pit in today's session I'm going to walk
through an example of training and
deploying a machine learning model I'll
be leaning heavily on the Tidy models
which is a framework for machine
learning in r that I work on to develop
my model along the way I'll show you how
posit team eases some of the pain points
of model development that I
encounter during today's session I'll
lay out three highlevel steps for
building a machine learning model and
then spend some time with each of those
steps individually before concluding
with resources where you can learn more
about tidy models and about posit team
after I present we'll be hanging out for
a live Q&A so please feel free to ask
questions as we go and I'm looking
forward to spending
time uh but with all all that out of the
way let's go ahead and get
started to talk about those first and
second steps I'll make use of some
slides and then for step three I'll drop
into a live demo using posit connect and
posit
workbench if you're interested in
spending more time with these slides or
checking out the source code behind this
presentation uh you can go to the link
in the footer of these slides that's
github.com
simonp couch mutagen
I've put together a diagram of sort of
the highlevel process for developing a
machine learning model um and the three
steps that I'm talking about are kind of
called out with these three hex stickers
in uh the
corners in the top right corner that
first step is to collect data and to
spend time with it uh cleaning data
visualizing it understanding it are all
important first steps to building a
machine learning model
when I do each of those steps I end up
spending a lot of time with the Tidy
verse packages which some of you may
have heard
of once I move on to training and
evaluating models uh I use the Tidy
models packages which I work on day
to-day and a common issue that people
run into when they're building models
with tidy models or any model
development software is uh running out
of computational resources if you're
working in an environment with lots of
data or you're trying to evaluate really
complex models uh you can run out of
computational resources really quickly
and for me this is a place where a posit
workbench is really key uh recently I've
started using it when I run into this
situation and it uh allows me to drop
into a computational environment where
um I have more resources and can
complete that uh model training more
quickly
once a model is trained it's time to get
it into the hands of people that will
use it uh and that's where the V package
comes in vver is free and open source
and it provides tools to to version
models deploy models and monitor them to
ensure that they continue to perform as
you expect them to once they're out into
the
world vver is tightly integrated with
posit connect uh which offers all sorts
of tooling for uh getting the outputs of
analysis into the right
hands so first let's talk about what do
I even mean when I say uh machine
learning or a machine learning
model one example is a Netflix movie
recommendation uh if you've ever gone to
somebody else's house and seen the
movies that are recommended to them you
might notice that they're quite
different than what you might see at
your own house that's because the movies
that are recommended to you and the
thumbnails that are part of those
recommendations are outputs of machine
learning models and based on your
viewing history and the things that
you've said you're interested in uh
Netflix will recommend different movies
to
you another example um on Zillow if
you're looking at houses or apartments
there are estimates of the uh value of
the property or the rent that they would
expect you to pay if you were to live
there so that's another example of a
machine learning
model or email spam filters so um all of
our emails whenever we get an email at
first there's a filter that looks at the
subject line and if you've received an
email from that person before and if
there are any typos inside of the email
and based on information like that um a
model will try to predict whether an
email is Spam or not and if it does
predict that the email is Spam it will
go to a
folder so the thing that all of these
share is that they are guessing the
value of an outcome using
predictors for example in the email spam
filters the outcome is whether that
email is Spam or not and the predictors
are those things I mentioned like the
subject line and the number of typos
inside and other things like
that for a Zillow property value
estimate that might be
something like the square footage of the
house or the apartment how recently it
was renovated what area it's in and for
Netflix movie recommendations that's
things like your stated interests in
movies that you're interested in to how
long you spent watching movies in
different
subcategories another example of a
machine learning model is one that this
presentation is based on day-to-day my
responsibility is just to develop tools
to build models um and so I often don't
spend a lot of time building models
myself but doing so helps us better
understand the perspectives of our users
and so we try to make time to really
delve in on a modeling problem as often
as we can so recently uh my colleague
maxkon and I spent some time to uh
develop a model and work through the
process to deploy it using uh posit
workbench in posit connect and wrote
about that on the posit
blog
in this blog post we talk through a
process that's really similar to the one
that I'll talk through with you today
where we explore data we situate with
our modeling problem we develop a model
to best understand that data and then we
deploy it using
connect so the process of machine
learning with posit team again I'll just
underscore those three different
sections before we dive in on them first
we'll spend some time to understand and
clean data with the Tidy verse and then
we'll train and evaluate models with
tidy models in workbench for both of
these sections I'll just work through
some slides and if you're interested in
the details you can uh look at the
source code of the analysis and the
source code for these slides at
github.com slim andp couch slm
mutagen once we've done so uh we need to
get that model into the hands of you
users and that's where vver and connect
come
in so let's start off with understanding
and cleaning
data in Pharmaceuticals mutagen AIA
refers to a Drug's tendency to increase
the rate of mutations due to damage
caused to
DNA mutagenicity is a key indicator that
a drug may be a carcinogen or cancer
causing mutagenicity can be evaluated
with a lab test so uh a person can test
whether a drug is a mutagen uh using a
standard wet lab procedure but those
tests are costly and those tests are
time
intensive so a group of scientists in
our example problem converges to ask the
question what if a machine learning
model could predict mitogenicity using
known drug
information that is if scientists are
spending time with a new drug using
information that they already have they
can predict whether a drug is a mutagen
or not which will allow them to iterate
more quickly when they're developing new
drugs The Source data that we'll be
working with is called mutagen table
it's a tble with uh over 4,000 rows and
notably over 1,500 predictors so in this
First Column we have whether the drug is
a mutagen or whether it's a
non-mutagen and for each of those
compounds as well we have a whole lot of
predictors uh giving us other
information we can use to predict
whether a drug is a mutagen or not so
you're probably thinking to yourself if
I have 1,500 little pieces of
information about this drug it surely
must be pretty uh straightforward to
predict
that it turns out it's not quite that
simple
uh on this plot I've plotted two of the
predictors and um each of those points
is also colored according to whether the
drug is actually a mutagen or whether
it's a non-mutagen so colors in blue are
mutagens colors in yellow are
non-mutagens on the x- axis we have the
molecular weight and Y AIS is the
partition coefficient it doesn't matter
whether you understand either of these
two predictors I really don't understand
them
but uh the point here is that it's
really hard just using the information
we have here to separate between the
blue points and the yellow points only
knowing uh the value of these two
predictors I can choose another two of
them right now I'm showing the number of
heavy atoms and the log of the average
veilance
connectivity uh whatever those two
predictors mean again we're seeing that
it's really hard to sort of draw a line
here that would easily separate the blue
points and the yellow points and this is
the goal that our machine learning model
will try to solve so if you're like me
you're feeling a little bit intimidated
about uh tackling
this this is where we move on to the
step of training and evaluating
models so for this portion of the
presentation instead of walking through
through the notebook that does the
training in the Val the evaluating I'll
uh leave it to folks to look through the
notebooks that are on that GitHub page
after the
presentation uh and instead I'll try to
answer the question of why you might be
interested in using tidy models over
other modeling Frameworks that are out
there the first reason why you should be
interested in using tidy models is that
tidy models is consider istent in a way
that other modeling Frameworks and
modeling packages are
not an example that I'll use to call
this out here we can start off by uh
showing the code to fit a linear model
using the LM function with tidy
models and a linear model using only the
LM
function on the left hand side there's
just one line of code uh we're using the
example Mt cars data set here if you're
familiar with it we're we're saying we
want to use all of the predictors on in
the Mt cars data to predict the outcome
which is the miles per gallon or
MPG and to do so we'll use the Mt cars
data on the right hand side the code
does the same thing except the Tidy
models wrapper has been dropped on top
of that
function the code reads we'll use a
linear regression use the LM function as
our computational engine and we'll fit
that model using uh the same data set in
the same pre-processing formula miles
per gallon as a function of
everything so when you see this you
might
think it seems a whole lot easier to
just go ahead and use LM it's only one
line of code and I hear you where we
really see the value of Tidy models
though is when we start to to introduce
complexity into the modeling pipeline so
let's say you're using the LM function
and it's not doing everything you need
it to do and you want to add for example
a regularization term to your linear
regression if you're not familiar with
that doesn't matter to uh understand
what I'm about to demonstrate here I
want you to look at that line three in
the Tidy models portion of the code
where I've set the engine to
LM if I want to transition that code to
instead use glim net all that I need to
do is change the the portion of the code
that said LM to instead say glim
net and you can see on the left hand
side it was much more than just one of
the lines of code that needed to change
uh instead here glim net for its first
argument is going to take all of the
predictors and they can only be a matrix
so thanks thankfully here in mty cars
all of the predictors are numbers anyway
and so they're one homogeneous type and
we can easily convert it with as.
Matrix and then instead of the name of
the outcome variable like it was in LM
the uh outcome here is specified as the
actual uh Vector of values in the Mt
cars data set so that's Mt cars dollar
sign
MPG
to transition that code I needed to know
not only that glim net existed and was
able to perform
regularization but I needed to look at
the documentation to see how that
function wanted the uh predictors to be
formatted how it wanted the outcome to
be formatted uh whether it needed any
additional arguments which of the
functions in the package I needed to use
to do so and again in tidy models all I
needed to do was change the value of of
that engine
argument and The Story Goes the same way
with any other engine you can
imagine let's say instead of glim net I
wanted to use the H2O package which
gives me access to all sorts of uh
machine learning techniques uh
implemented in Java so it's super
fast with tidy models all I need to do
is change the value of engine to
H2O but with H2O I need to initialize an
H2O server I need to convert that Mt
car's data set to a data set that's
compatible with H2O using as.
H2O and I assign a label to that Mt cars
data set the string Mt cars and then I
passed that string as the last argument
to h2o's linear model function h2g
LM also the H2O glm function doesn't
take the values of the predictors
instead it takes the names so I take the
names of the Mt cars data set the
portion of it that has the predictors in
it and uh the same goes for the outcome
it takes the name of the outcome in the
Mt cars data set as a
string so all of this uh change in the
code again I would need to spend time to
uh read through the documentation see
how that interface changes and only once
I've done so can I make use of the
functionality within
H2O and with tidy models I just get that
for free by changing the engine
argument another reason to use tidy
models is safety tidy models is designed
to uh Safeguard you from common modeling
pitfalls one of the things that tidy
models is designed to protect you from
from is data leakage a 2023 review found
data leakage to be a widespread failure
mode in machine learning based science
data leakage is when information from
the set you're going to use or the
portion of the data that you're going to
use to evaluate your model somehow leaks
into the portion of the data that you're
using to train your model if a model is
being evaluated on data that it's seen
already then it will
perform better than on data that it
hasn't seen before and so it will seem
like your model is performing really
well but it's actually not and you'll
only learn that the model isn't
performing well once it's deployed so in
our example uh in the mutagen example if
our model seems to be able to classify
drugs as either mutagens or non-mutagens
really really well if we go ahead and
deploy that thinking that the model is
performing perfectly then uh scientists
will mistakenly uh interpret the results
from that model and uh take them at face
value another common failure mode is
overfitting uh overfitting leads to
analysts believing models are more
performant than they actually are so
this is really similar to that first
failure mode where uh in the case of an
overfit model in our mutagen example the
model is going to perform really really
well on um the portion of the data that
was used to train the model and if we
don't have tools to then evaluate the
model on data that it hasn't seen before
then uh that model might just learn
every little intricacy of the training
data and won't generalize well to data
that it hasn't seen
before
a last component of safety that uh tidy
models make sure to protect its users
from is irreproducibility
implementations of the same machine
learning model give differing results in
many uh popular implementations of
machine learning algorithms resulting in
irreproducibility of modeling
results so each of the citations listed
in the bottom here in order are reports
on data leakage and overfitting and ir
reproducibility and tidy models is
designed to safeguard you from all of
them we developed this software so that
it's really hard to do the things that
are wrong and that an analyst would
commonly want to do and makes the things
that are usually difficult but pay off
in the long run it makes those things
really
easy another reason why you want want to
use tidy models is that tidy models is
designed to be
communicable all tidy models objects or
at least many of them have visualization
functions called autop plot that are
associated with
them so if I make a um receiver
operating curve with the Tidy models
which is a tool used to uh evaluate
models I can pass that object to autop
plot and see what that curve looks like
in 2D space
I can also pass for example the results
of trying to tune a random Forest
algorithm again I just pass that result
to the autoplot function and we have
built-in visualization procedures for
that uh model
object the same story goes for iterative
search results things like Bean
optimization simulated and kneeling
these are Advanced Mach machine learning
techniques that are built into tidy
models when when I use tidy models to
generate these results I can understand
them by quickly plotting
them another example to use tidy models
is completeness there's built-in support
for 99 machine learning models uh once
you load the Tidy models packages and
there are even more packages if you load
uh extensions that are contributed by
the
community Teddy models is also complete
with reference to data pre-processing
techniques with the three main packages
for pre-processing that are loaded when
you load TIY models uh we load in 102
different ways to process data that
comes in raw and turn it into something
that a model knows what to do
with and I've hinted at this already but
again tid models is extensible if you
can't find the machine learning
technique you need which is either the
machine learning model or the
pre-processing technique you can add it
yourself we have uh apis that are
designed to make it really easy to
contribute your own extensions that are
designed with your problem context in
mind the last reason I'll list here is
deployability and this will bring us
into that final step three that we'll uh
drop into the live demo for tidy models
is tightly integrated with v which is a
free and open source package for model
deployment Inver is configured to
quickly and easily and securely uh ship
a model to posit connect which is part
of The Suite of products in posit
team so with that said let's go ahead
and drop into a live demo I'll spin up a
workbench session and we'll use that
session uh to train a model and then uh
send it off to posit
connect
once I've logged in this is what my
posit workbench instance looks like I'm
going to start out by spinning up a new
session and this is what I was talking
about where I can get access to
resources Beyond uh what my laptop is
capable of in terms of computing power
so I have access to uh different types
of clusters and then uh for that cluster
different options in terms of the number
of CPUs and the amount of Ram so I'm
going to go ahead and start this session
as an R Studio Pro
project this will just take a couple
seconds to spin up and once it's wrapped
up it will look a lot like uh an
instance of the r Studio IDE if you've
ever worked with one of those locally on
your
laptop so from here I'm at the point
where I have some code that I want to
use to train a model and this code is
hosted on um this GitHub repository that
I have here Simon pouch
mutagen this repository has all the
source code for training the model as
well as the source code for the slides
if you're interested in it and I'm going
to go ahead and copy the link to this
GitHub repository and then I will start
a new project and the new project will
be from Version
Control I'll start it up from git and
paste in the URL there and I'll call
this project
mutagen this will also just take a
couple seconds to spin up and once it's
done so all of the uh data and the
source files that were inside of that
GitHub repository are going to be also
uh available to me inside of posit
workbench so for instance there's a read
me me in this repository uh giving some
highle information on what's in there
here's all the source code for the
slides in this slide folder what I'm
going to open up is uh Source here which
has a Cordo document that has all of the
source code that I used to uh
pre-process my data and start
understanding it in step one and then
moving into that step two which is uh
developing and training the model and
ultimately deciding on the final
fit so you can see up here in my
environment I went ahead and um loaded
in the output of final fit from file so
normally in my workflow I would go ahead
and train the model here on workbench
and since I've done so already I already
have the output of that from here and
instead we're going to move right on to
that last step step three which is
getting that trained model into the
hands of the people that are going to
use
it this is actually really simple
there's only a few lines of code you
need once you have a a fitted model with
tidy models to then go ahead and deploy
that model to uh posit
connect the first step is to pass that
trained model to V model which is a
function from vver which will put some
wrappers around it and make sure it's
ready to go to
deploy I'll also call board connect here
and assign that output to
board uh if you're unfamiliar with this
function this is from pins and uh if you
want to learn more about the pins
package I think it was the last um posit
team demo where they covered the
functionality
there so we're running into an error
here and what this telling me is that we
don't have a uh posit connect server to
that we're connected to already so we
can actually go ahead and do that and
it's pretty simple if I go to tools
Global
options publishing these are the uh the
accounts from which I can publish from
so I'm going to go ahead and just click
connect here to posit connect and this
is pre-filled for me because I'm working
on my workbench instance uh inside of a
posit
team uh account so that's pre-filled in
there I'll click next it's going to wait
for
authentication um and
it will authenticate to my posit account
and now that it's uh authenticated I can
click connect account and
apply and so that's all I needed to do
to link my workbench session up to posit
connect so I can try running that board
connect code
again and it was successful nice so I'm
on the connect instance that I have
access to through pause it I will then
pass that final fit object that vver
made to me to vver pin write to write it
to the board I've just
created and now that final fit V object
is pinned to the board on posit connect
so once that uh pin is on connect I'll
go ahead and deploy the model that I
have uh assigned to this Simon couch
mutagen
and you'll see here down in the console
that viver is doing all sorts of work to
uh bundle up everything that that model
needs to create predictions from new
data um into a an object that can be uh
passed off to
connect so that happened pretty quickly
it just uh brought us over to a connect
uh window where vver is showing the
deployment so the on the left side of
the screen screen is what a user would
see if they pulled up this model API and
so there's all sorts of metadata about
the model uh there's examples from which
analysts can ping uh put together code
to Ping the model uh for new
predictions and then on the right side
and this is um a really nice benefit for
a lot of people there's all sorts of
access to security features and metadata
so uh by default it's only uh available
to specific users or groups and you can
add those in but you can also make it
available to all users within your
organization uh and then there's all
sorts of other meta metadata that you
have access to uh as
well so I hadn't deployed a model using
vver until um I was working on the blog
post that I mentioned earlier and I was
really surprised at how
straightforwardly it came together um
and so I would encourage you if you uh
are working in an instance of workbench
in your organization to go ahead and try
to do that same thing deploy the model
that is uh publicly available on my
GitHub and see what
happens so with the third step of
deploying our model wrapped up we really
touched on all portions of this diagram
at this point at first we took a look at
our data we situated ourselves with the
modeling problem we visualized some of
the variables and got a sense of the
challenge that we up
for we then moved on to training and
evaluating a model using tidy models uh
in this demo we really just talked about
why using tidy models would be
advantageous to your modeling workflow
but if you're more interested in how we
actually went about doing that I would
encourage you to pull down that script I
had uh up during the demo run some of
the code and uh see how it feels for you
and I'll show you some resources after
this where you can learn more about how
to use tidy
models after that we went on to deploy
the model to posit Connect using vver
and as you saw that really only took a
couple lines of code so we very quickly
went from a final trained model to a
model that's in the hands of users at
our
organization if you're interested in
learning more um to learn more about
tidy verse how to uh understand and
clean and visualize data uh the arur
data science book at R4 ds.
hadley.ma with our book at
tmw.com Team there's all sorts of
information on the products that are
included as part of posit team and uh
links for places to learn more and
lastly if you want to see these slides
again or poke around with the source
code that's underneath them or poke
around with the source code to train a
model using tidy models again that uh
code is at github.com
Simon pouch SL
mutagen I really appreciate the welcome
to uh drop in the posit team demo thank
you for having me and uh looking forward
to
questions thanks so much Simon really
appreciate you joining us here today for
the demo and for sticking around for the
Q&A um just wanted to let everybody know
that this YouTube will push you over to
the live Q&A in just a second here but
if you want to ask questions you can
post in the YouTube chat over there but
you can also use the slido link that we
have up on the screen so you can ask
questions anonymously if you go to P
os.it demo Das
questions but one thing that I wanted to
add is that we have these monthly end
to-end workflow demos on the last
Wednesday of every month so if you
joined us here today for your first one
we'd love to have you join us again um
and so you can add those to your
calendar with just the short link
P.I team- demo and that add to calendar
link will point you to all of the
recordings as well um but we'll see you
over there in the Q&A in just a
second